I've been looking for a house for about
nine years and I found one but it's kind
of a flipper and it's about $2 million
so I didn't know if it would be wise in
our situation looking for a house for
nine years is weird let's start with
that you you want to build a you want to
buy a house for $2 million that you have
to fix up and then you're going to flip
it I love the land no no I'm just saying
like it's not a flipper then if you're
not going to flip it it's just you're
buying a house that needs a lot of work
yeah it looks like flipper conditions
what's the household
income together our base salaries is
about 520 you can qualify for a 15year
mortgage and you can afford a 15year
mortgage I think we could no I know that
we could qualify for a 15year mortgage
qualify for that I just don't want our
house payment to be that high because I
know my husband will be against that so
that's why I want to do like a 30 until
the 20 or a 30 until the interest rates
are lower no you take out a 15 and when
the interest rates are lower you
refinance